الى كوسوفو حيث اندلعت مواجهات بين الشرطه
ومواطنين من اصول صربيا احرقت فيها سيارات
للشرطه في البلدات الشماليه على الحدود مع
صربيا
انها تتخذ اجراءات وتدابير امنيه لمنع
جميع الانشطه الاجراميه في البلد وتقدم
المساعده لبلديات
اخرى اعلن الرئيس صربي الكسندر وضع الجيش
في حاله تاهب قتالي ينقصها وامر وحداته
بالاقتراب من الحدود مع كوسوفو فقال وزير
الدفاع الصربي ميلوس
فوسفيتش انه اصدر اوامر بتحرك قوته بشكل
عاجل الى الحدود مع كوسوفو واضاف ان من
الواضح ان الارهاب يستهدف الطائفه الصربيه
في كوسوفو حسب تعبيره
في هذه الاثناء حمل كبير الموظفين في
رئاسه كوسوفو فيلا صربيا مسؤوليه التصعيد
في المناطق الشماليه من كوسوفو وقال كبير
موظفي الرئاسه في كوسوفو في تغريده ان اي
محاوله تسلل لعسكريين في زي مدني الى شمال
البلاد ستعرض السلامه والاستقرار في
المنطقه للخطر واتهم النظام السربي بتصعيد
الوضع لضمان بقائه
وفي بيان المشترك عبرت كل من الولايات
المتحده وفرنسا وايطاليا والمانيا
وبريطانيا عن ادانتها لقرار حكومه كوسوفو
بالدخول بالقوه الى المباني البلديه في
شمال كوسوفو رغم الدعوه الى ضبط النفس
ودعت الدول الخمس سلطات كوسوفو في البيان
الى التراجع عن على
الفوق في
التصحيح معنى منا منا
بدايه كيف هو الوضع في هذه المناطق
الحدوديه
هذه الليله او ليله ماضيه مدت بدون اي
تبرات في تلك المنطقه وهذا الصباح ايضا
هدوء هدوء حاذر يسود المنطقه الحدوديه بين
صربيا وكوسوفه وبالذات ثلاثه بلديات التي
ذكرته في في خبر اذا هناك اتهامات متبادله
بين الاطراف بين صربيا وبين بين بين
بلاغراض وبين بريشنا من يقف وراء هذه
التوترات الاخيره وصربيا تشير وفي مجلس
مجلس الامن القومي الذي تم انقاذه الجلسه
صباحا هذا اليوم تم تمديد حاله التاهب
القصوى في جميع المناطق صربيا وايضا
لديها قوه والامكانيه لحمايه الشعبها في
اي مكان يتبادلون فيه من جانب اخر قال
رئيس الوزراء كسوفي البي ان حمايه مفاصل
الدوله وسياده الدوله
هو واجب بالفعل ويجب على الجميع سكان
الكسوفه ان يطبقوا ويحترموا القانون
ويتطلب القانون ان تنفذ جميع
نتائج الانتخابات التي اقيمت في ثلاثه
بلديات في شمال الكوسوفه في نهايه شهر
الماضي اذا في هذه الاثناء هدوء وتم
انسحاب وكثير من الشرطه الكوسوفيه التي
تدعم القوى السياسيه في دخول الى تلك
المباني نعلم جيدا ان يوم السبت والاحد هو
يوم الاجازه ايام الاجازه نهايه الاسبوع
اذا لن تكون هناك هذه دوائر لن تشتغل خلال
يومين القادمين اذا هدوء الان لكن لا لا
كيف يحاسب الكثير من المحللين لا يتجه نحو
التصعيد
هل هناك تفعل على البيان الامريكيه
الاوروبيه الذي يدعو كوسوفو الى التراجع
ووقف التصعيد فورا
نعم بالفعل رئيس وزراء كوسوفيال بن كورتي
يصرح ان يحترم اراي الاتحاد الاوروبي
واصدقاء الغربيين لكن يجب ان تنفذ القانون
ويطبق الدستور الكسوفي الذي يقول ان ثلت
تلك البلديات الثلاثه هي من ضمن من ضمن
دوله كوسوفو وسيادتها من جانب الاخر
بالاغراض ترحب وتقول ان ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي وقوى الغربيه فاهمه تماما من يقف
وراء اعمال التخريب ومن يريد زعزعه الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه بالفعل اذا نسمع
حتى في البيانات نسمع التفسيرات
مختلفه من اطراف المختلفه
شكرا لك احمد مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من
سرايفه